diese engagiert ihre wohnung durch einen
bombenangriff
ihr mann ist im krieg irgendwo wenn er
überhaupt noch lebt
den dreijährigen sohn bringt sie bei
ihrer mutter unter sie selbst bekommt
ein zimmer in wilmersdorf zugewiesen und
verbringt im april 45 die meiste zeit im
luftschutzkeller allein unter fremden
sie hat keinen kontakt zu ihrer familie
den anderen in der notgemeinschaft teilt
sie ihre angst ihre ungewissheit sie
alle ahnen es ist nur eine frage der
zeit bis die russen sie finden werden
doch was passiert dann mit ihnen
hat irgendeiner anita weiß ich was
zurechtgebastelt dass wir auch mal
nachrichten würden für die russen
es gibt doch gar nicht sein ich will
hier raus
ergiebiger sie bringen unser land wird
dann bestimmt nicht werden
bei den erfolgreichen gegenangriffen
sind die deutschen soldaten ab klausel
spuren wollte wissen ob terrors gestoßen
in emmersdorf und den anderen
ostpreußischen orten hat die den sowjet
orden von ihrer führung gegeben eine
volle handlungsfreiheit gegenüber der
zivilbevölkerung bestialische
auswirkungen gefunden geschändete frauen
erschlagene kreise ermordete kinder
verlässt kurz den keller um sich oben im
haus zu waschen
auf der straße sieht sie soldaten will
sie ansprechen
doch im allerletzten moment erkennt sie
das sind russen
sind deutsche soldaten hier bringen ganz
sicher
ganz sicher moment für uns allen ein
stein vom herzen
und dann hieß es da ist ja so nett und
jahr gut vielleicht noch nicht so
schlimm und das war dann noch so eine
gnadenfrist uns beschert waren russische
soldaten schockiert
verschleppt
zweieinhalb bis drei stunden später kam
dann der leser nahm er mich mit raus und
ich musste auch freunde gehen und hat
mir unverständlich zu verstehen gegeben
was er wollte er machte seine hose auf
und ich sagte nein und fing an mich zu
wehren und da habe ich weiß ich
natürlich also irgendwie mit diesem werk
hatte wohl einfach den kopf gehauen über
moment war ich wohl weg wie ich dann
wieder zu mir kam zerrissen und es war
ein wunder dass er mich nicht
erschlossen
mit einem 1
mein base kaputt aber deine frau
und da bin ich in diesem befehl
sie sahen bis zum frühen morgen habe ich
deine legen ich bin 1000 tode gestorben
ich habe immer gedacht die kommt zurück
und vielleicht schießen so viel gab also
eine salbe da reihen verstehen sie und
ich da drin und also da hab ich gedacht
nein noch eine nacht bleibst du nicht in
diesem befehl
hast du los
und jetzt die lager sowie zurück
wo sind denn die anderen frauen genauso
golf
was für die 2
sein zentrum
es für sie
das
haben sie übrig
kurz nach kriegsende stellt in seiner
fest dass sie schwanger ist
in einem krankenhaus in cuxhaven wird
die abtreibung vorgenommen nachdem ihr
erster mann im krieg vermisst blieb
heiratete 1948 erneut und bekommt zwei
kinder